I've got a few minutes left and and I'm
gonna do something that I've not usually
known for doing and that is I'm gonna be
serious okay
and and I mean that in all earnest
because I'm deeply troubled and I'm
deeply troubled and I'm gonna raise this
ugly word in front of you which I
normally wouldn't do and maybe I'll get
the disobedience prize for doing it but
but the word that I'm gonna raise is
politics okay and I'm deeply concerned
about politics and this is not a
partisan statement I don't give a damn
who you voted for or what country you
voted in if you could vote but the ugly
head of politics for the last seven
months has reared itself in ways that
undermine and are deleterious to what
the media laboratory has stood for 235
years
and what I mean by that is that politics
has driven culture away from science and
art and that's what we've spent 30 years
exploring that's what the laboratory
began with and that's the warp and the
weft and the fabric of society we began
in the 1970s by building technologies of
expression technologies of learning and
technologies of art we digitized
everything and the theory of that was
that we would reduce the friction and
democratize the technologies of
expression and of learning and of art so
if there was a press that was expensive
and caused monopoly rents and preventing
you from expressing everybody
we built presses don't buy a press build
one if you thought the editorial content
was too narrow and you couldn't express
yourself then we built the tools that
allowed you to do it we said don't read
it be it and that's what the laboratory
had done for 30 years and we were never
about to bits we were always about the
people in 1986 Judith don't a throat a
thesis during the first iteration of
this labs foray into the world of news
and she explored the concept of context
of how how an article appeared the
typeface the headline the masthead could
impact its information as well as the
content 10 years later when the web
started to blossom we looked at the web
and said it's an T design it doesn't
allow you to express yourself so
our student hock only built a thing
called CSS cascading stylesheets and
that's what made the web what it is
today and gives the web the look that it
has today those are the kinds of things
that we did it was about people it
wasn't life but now politics is driving
culture and it's driving culture away
from those principles and that's deeply
concerning and I think it's something
that we all have to think about but
we're the Media Lab we don't just think
about it and we don't get depressed and
I don't want you to be depressed we
don't get mad we get even okay and if
you look around at the laboratory today
then what you'll see is that triumvirate
of expression and learning and art has
indeed been augmented by a fourth leg
and the fourth leg is the leg of society
and you'll see that throughout the lab
in the two days as you wander through it
whether it's manifest itself in Kevin s
felts work on the inclusion of the
community in the diffusion of science
throughout that community whether it's
iya at Rollins work in allowing four
million people to test-drive an
autonomous vehicle so they can decide
whether it makes the decisions that they
would choose to have it make whether
it's a czars work on analytical
exposition that allows people to
understand data and see and visualize
that data or Civic media's group on
getting people engaged in it or Sandi's
and Deb's group on social analytics to
understand it or even our little work in
viral communications on ways to kind of
influence and enable people to do that
kind of thing again that's what our
response to that is and you'll see it in
your trip through the lab it's adding
that word Society back into the words
expression learning and art and
hopefully we'll do that in a way that
manifests itself and impacts and
revitalizes that change and why do we
want to do that we want to do that
because we're going to build better
people by doing that and we're going to
build better people with you and if we
build better people we'll build a better
world and that will be the world that
will be the world
we want to live in and we will all
thrive by doing it and we'll reverse
that trend of politics
so enjoy your two days and thank you
very much
[Applause]